60 year old Julie Albertson is known as
the Texas pie Queen thanks to her tasty
Tarts that come with a little something
extra baked into them and the ingredient
is true love Julie says when she first
met her husband she baked him a
buttermilk pie to seal the deal and now
she does the same thing for other people
Julie says her pastries are like prayers
oh my gosh you can only get away with
saying that if you're from Texas my pods
are like prayers right when she rolls
out the dough she focuses on a couple's
future together and we have some of her
love pies right here look Drew what a
day okay all right so if if she's saying
you're gonna find somebody special or
have love should you eat it thinking
about love you absolutely should all
right so I want to see your face now I
know who you're going to be thinking
about hello
um I'm I'm gonna go with olive and
Frankie oh cute